[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we have
with us today lawrence cow what did we
do right that we were able to get him
back on here man he's the coolest guy
ever yes lawrence is the coolest guy
ever
you know like oh you're just bored okay
because i was like yeah
films and tv shows and in between he's
like
i have no lines to read i'm just
chilling
you're all fake i'm not really doing
anything i'm just pretending it's all
social media you know i'm just like yeah
that's like me yeah i'm like so you
stockpile all these galas and all that
[ __ ] and then like yeah
to record me yeah
on all these red carpets you're breaking
the fourth wall of social media right
that's like the fifth wall man yep so
you tell me i just run out of content
and i'm like [ __ ] i've been posted in
like three weeks bro and i had to do
something you gotta hire people so
you're telling me that video of you at
that party and you talking to his wife
was like fake
that was one of the coolest videos i've
ever seen i mean ask ask bart about it
because me me and bart we we set that up
and um
yeah it was all um fake
you were the coolest guy ever in that
[ __ ] ad though did you see me in the
i was really cool yeah you were like
dancing in the background that was
really cool you were an ad that was my
favorite kindergarten i've ever seen oh
so the mcdonald's one
it's just lawrence being himself it's
for their new dance uh classes online oh
that one is like a kid just dojo app
thing yeah yeah right it's fun it's my
biggest pimp ever in that video i guess
so whoever oh dude yeah i like that
video we're sitting in the nice chair
old spice guy bro that's what we should
be we need yeah we should call them
youngsters
do you have an ideal like sponsor like
let's say like like you know what once
people like become mega movie stars they
have like a voice when they work with
like chandeliers sandwiches
right yeah yeah yeah i love these
sandwiches i like their wings
mr baguette got better coffee i've never
had mr baguette have you guys had food
long i mean long is that subway
it's a coffee shop
that's amazing
is
i love that spot dude like i don't know
how it is now because like coveted
inflation and all this [ __ ] made the
prices go higher but i [ __ ] you now you
could go there get a [ __ ] sandwich
for like it's like two or three bucks
right it's fighting unheard of get one
free you get a bowl of fun there too for
like five bucks for a dollar just
getting anything for two or three bucks
that's amazing what damn that's crazy
you have a feast for like 11
yep
11 dude do you actually have a dream uh
sponsorship or anything like that um no
not really i haven't really thought
about that endorsement deal no i don't
know i don't know what are you
interested in you're never like man i
can't wait till pampers [ __ ] picks me
up
hey no that's a good one are you into
[ __ ] like watches or shoes oh yeah i
like doc martens
[Laughter]
you could be the new men's warehouse guy
you're gonna like the way you look that
was
come on dude that would be dope if
you're the new face of doc mars because
you know like in all uh movies and like
commercials there's like the there's
more and more asian presents i don't
know if you guys notice that yeah but
then i'm actually the skin heads that
are the face of dark matter he's gonna
change the game
rebranding
no longer gonna be an outfit for
skinheads maybe i can become a skinhead
yeah
rebrand and rebrand skinheads and me so
that i can be
because the skinny brain
i was like
because you guys are like you know what
it's a new era we need to be more
diverse yeah
we need to include people with
and asians are white adjacent yeah so
perfect they're like model minority so
like maybe we can let give them a pass
you know yeah you don't even need to
bleach your skin dude yeah yeah good
that's true go get a pale taiwanese boy
what are we that's that's how we're
going to do it i'm going to call uh
doctor
i'll call doc martens as your fake
manager be like you need an asian
skinhead yeah
we got one of them are you guys aware
that your branding is mainly skin heads
i know where you can fix are you aware
girls like goth chicks gotcha where are
those boots what a crazy realization if
doc martens was like they're right it
really is like no wonder we haven't been
selling that much these days and ever
since the product placement on american
history x
[ __ ] up
they put us in a box everybody in that
was wearing freaking doc martens at that
party i was like dude i won yeah yeah
but i feel like nowadays cool people
wear doc marks you know people that like
are into fashion and stuff wear doc
martens that's why i can never i don't
wear them that's why you're excluded
from those are cool thank you dude you
got doc martin's on right now he's got
doc martin or something actually dude
[Laughter]
or maybe it's inside
just like it's inside all of
[Laughter]
i thought all of them were steel toes
like i guess so like you can't you can't
really like let me see if they're still
taller i mean i don't know i wouldn't
see the perfect one
yes it is
oh that's you that's that's that's tough
right huh
no no that's not steel tall because i
wanna yeah it's a casual shoe so it's
like i think it is
thanks
it's steel toe
in the military one of our combat boots
with steel toe and then because there's
like different things for different
occasions and when we first got issued
those i was like [ __ ] yeah and there's
this back part of our warehouse that no
one was why are you laughing that's
because i already know what you're gonna
do there's a back part of the warehouse
that no one really cared about you know
and i was just like
and i would just go it just [ __ ] suck
i was right dude i was right it stinked
all the time
you look around the office
there's literally a boot in the [ __ ]
wall you feel like a lost hill
you know when colossus is dude you don't
feel [ __ ] on your toes
the reason why i was like that's
that's what people would do is because
immediately if i got some steel toe
boots they're so fun man i'm kicking
through i was kicking the doors i was
[ __ ]
and also every story from his childhood
involves him looking at a thing
processing and then destroying
flowers i wonder if i could kick these
apart
[Laughter]
you should get uh your kids some steel
toe boots oh no no no no no no for your
house so you can like you know he's
gonna [ __ ] my house up yeah i know
exactly but it'll be fun
one of you is going to [ __ ] it up
that's true
he's going to do it again you know his
guy
yeah you know what's in there he's
already [ __ ] [ __ ] up right now what
is he [ __ ] up these days
um like if i leave him in the shower too
long then all the shampoo is on the
floor
he's just like this
all of it is on the floor and i'm like
[ __ ] that the whole bottle of shampoo we
just wasted
just kind of [ __ ] like that at least
your floor will be clean
right it'll be slippery yeah yeah just
everything's george right now yeah i'm
like just pumping it all out how much is
in the shampoo bottle everything he does
i'm like oh man it's infinite yeah
there's a lot more like we'll be [ __ ]
uh like at a restaurant right and we all
have [ __ ] tap water
and then this guy's like this was like a
napkin and then like my my water's open
you know and he's like
and i'm like no you can't he's like ah
man
oh god damn it dad
but then when i look at him i'm like
i know what it's you're trying to
scratch somebody can't get another water
please
that's good i love that
that's cool that you do that i'm like
yeah there's three people here but can i
have five bottles of
the wine way to like you know to foster
his imagination and stuff like that he
has this itch he has to scratch and i
relate to it because that's why i did
all the weird [ __ ] like having
tourette's but for problematic [ __ ] yeah
he's probably gonna be a creative genius
when he goes because he's unfiltered
like nobody's saying no like you can't
oh
i do say no what are the things where's
the line where's the line
yeah uh the line so so far the line is
um
he
so originally
he would like draw on my desk
and then i'll give him paper i'm gonna
draw on the paper instead
and then he would like can i use this
and it's a highlighter i'm like sure
and then he started going permanent
marker and i'm like [ __ ] go ahead so he
ends up i'm like just stay on the paper
and then now it's all over
yeah so the note so when i saw that i
was like the absolute null is not on the
carpet or on the floor like at least
just you want to [ __ ] some [ __ ] up
drawing on my desk yeah so just like i
try to like let him breathe and be a
person but if it's gonna really [ __ ]
[ __ ] up then then no like he wants to
turn on the stove and so he could like
burn forks and whatever it might not
burn forks
he wants to get red hot yeah he's a
[ __ ] scientist
give him a bunch of burner dude that's
what he did he was a forge of sword man
today's video is brought to you by hello
tushy
all right guys i've been using tushy for
at least five years now and it has been
keeping my booty hole very very clean
yeah i love tushy um because number one
i don't know why but when i poop
i have a huge variation sometimes i got
the poops where you never get the poops
where it comes out and then you wipe
your butt and there's nothing on the
toilet paper yeah and then you even
taste it just double check
that was really clean but then sometimes
you just
wipe a million times and it never goes
away oh yeah those suck that's why but
days are freaking sick because it's
straight up taking a shower without
having to shower and also you don't use
that much toilet paper too because it
does a lot of the work for you and all
you got to do is dab it dry in most
occasions and also think about it right
if you walk outside barefoot and you're
just frolicking in the grass and you
step in the [ __ ] load of dodooki what
do you do do you just wipe your bottom
of the foot with a paper towel and put
socks and shoes back on no you don't and
it's essence that's what you're doing
after you take a dump you're not wiping
your butt with water you're just
smearing that [ __ ] all over yeah and
toushi is one of the easiest days to
install you can install it in less than
eight minutes you don't even need an
electrician you don't need a plumber you
can do it yourself so if that's
something that you're intimidated by
don't worry about it we want all of our
listeners to have clean bumps visit
hellotissue.com
off the record to get 10 off plus free
shipping right now tag us at hellotushi
on social media so we can celebrate your
clean butt with you that's
hellotushi.com off the record for 10
off
when we do [ __ ] i'm way more lenient
right like we were walking to the park
and then there's this big ass hill
that's like a construction site
so we'll go and then like when we walk i
let him go wherever so if he wants to
like go all the way up to the edge of
the neighborhood and go like this on the
fence of the walls i'm with him like
that oh
i do that and then so now when mom comes
he's walking and he just starts going
off the trail into the construction site
jill's like what are you doing
hey
[Music]
and she looks at me like you guys do
this
i'm like yeah we go there and then we
like throw rocks at the baseball field
some kids man that's hilarious
oh like we gotta discuss these things
we're on the same page because we're not
in the same batch what does geo tell you
about that she's like yo don't be
letting this [ __ ] dude i think
for her she's like
i [ __ ] it you know as long as it's not
harmful towards him or to someone else
just get the [ __ ] wiggles out because
like this phase isn't forever but i
think worry where are we some people
think you're in this phase until you're
[ __ ] 24. i'm like you get it out for
like two weeks and then they're on to
some other [ __ ] you know yeah what about
you
oh i don't know i have a lot of wiggles
[Laughter]
off yeah yeah yeah
what's your adult version of that what i
told you i'm like what if i if i had
like [ __ ] you money then i would want
like tractor wars or i want a tarn
feather a boeing 747 so it could be an
eagle in the sky
[Laughter]
tar and feather yeah tarn feather 747 or
i would like open up
like let's say david has an ice cream
shop i would literally open up one right
next to him
i could see you making like big
billboards too of just like you like
just chilling there like anthony lives
here yeah yeah
oh man if only you had that money
some billboard money dude i got i got
some wiggles too i gotta get out if you
had if you had unlimited budget to make
any feature what would that be
man i don't know what genre first of all
um
genre vietnamese
as a genre yeah
just generally vietnam
vietnamese genre that means anything
goes
i don't know
the movie like a romantic horror film
that also is a musical
first by night
paris by night horror story
like they got a vietnamese dude dressed
like a pirate five hot ass ladies in
bikinis and it's just like wild as [ __ ]
they still still stuck in 1975 and the
outfits are just outrageous
it's just like this 20-hour movie yeah
yeah or you remake hamilton but with all
some vietnamese yeah not like 100
vietnamese wait wait when did i become
obsessed with vietnamese people
subway thing
the food
man
that's now in your rep dude update your
imdb pro
a vietnamese person would you 100 do it
i've already done it oh wait yeah i had
to speak like vietnamese like some
vietnamese
what you're saying i like hit up tony
and charles about like pronunciations
and stuff but i'm like am i saying this
correctly yeah like you were yellow
facing yourself
a little bit a little bit i felt bad i'm
like should i be doing this but whatever
you could you could play a lot of
different asians yeah out of all the
asians though i feel like chinese can
pass vietnamese the most yeah yeah for
sure for sure you could play you could
play filipino too i think yeah i think
so yeah yeah you um
was it like one of those things where
you were just trying to get any role or
like that was a sick world or like it
was a cool role it was on it was on a
show called the originals and i played
like this witch
so i had to do like i didn't do like
these vietnamese spells you played a lot
like that you played a woman too no no
no
which can be men yeah i thought how dare
you were warlocks
is that the same as of 2022 guys i don't
know i don't know
yeah they could be witches right or
maybe apple is a warlock i don't know oh
yeah men can be specifically for
vietnamese people and you went
undercover or like any asian is fine
you're a vietnamese wizard like that's
the best thing i mean
his last name was nguyen
so like
yeah i mean i'm pretty sure they were
looking for like a good guy
[Laughter]
wait a minute he spoke english
[Laughter]
i had to carry this like uh this doll or
like this um
what are they called when you go oh like
a voodoo doll and then do a little chant
oh
but i forget i forgot i forgot what the
chant was
it was
number one
[Laughter]
you don't have a dream production if
like someone was like i'm going to give
you unlimited funding yeah i don't know
man i got to sit down and think about
that i would expand on that vietnamese
wizard character for you
okay
you make
it already have like an idea you've been
sitting on you're like oh this one just
needs like a big studio backing and real
for sure come to life you know i
actually haven't even thought about that
or even sat down and thought about like
something that's like super big budget i
got worried
i like the idea that he gets unlimited
budget and he still wants to be
[Laughter]
we were like but he's not even he's not
even vietnamese
speaking but he had unlimited budget
yeah yeah
that's why
doctor strange sounds like a normal
vietnamese neighbor
like you just have a normal guy down
he's like oh man that guy knocked a
straight
he's a chiropractor
i don't know because you know i feel
like ethnicities have trends like right
now korean is hot right yeah chinese was
so 1990s
it's up to me
[Laughter]
you can't be in it because you're
vietnamese yeah okay yeah but you're not
really yeah come on there's nobody's
real vietnamese people behind this yeah
it's gonna ruin it
it wouldn't be active if i'm playing
myself that's yeah so that's why you
can't get it we gotta get not vietnamese
characters to play vietnamese
people like japanese people actually i
don't know about japanese people they'll
be like yeah yeah
i guess that
that's that's what we need you need the
first one to be non-viet so that there's
a revolt and they go we need more viet
representation in viet films and then
start the movement so that's the purpose
of that movie and then again what's up
dog
you know what i mean we get all the
hitters we get jimmy boy okay because we
gotta get all the like the vietnamese
that weren't represented that we grew up
with johnny bang johnny dang starring
johnny dang
what do you mean yes okay i'll i'll
pitch you the as a fan yes what i think
you should do okay please please that
unfinished the unfinished story you have
on your youtube that's yeah when i get
this many likes i'm going to do part two
oh yeah
[Laughter]
how sick is that that's right like what
a dope-ass like variety it's wri it
writes itself
they'll be like dude look at this guy he
made this whole movie off of a part two
that he promised would come this guy has
range you know
he didn't even hit 20 000 views and he
still [ __ ] made it
and it's vietnamese but it will after
part two yeah yeah that's the twist is
that people go back and then they watch
that yeah and then in doing that it
validates what they've already seen
it's like it's like me man manifesting
the 20 000 viewership exactly by making
this yep and in particular part three we
have we introduced a new uh
uh uh a villain which is a filipino man
this is gonna be crazy
[Laughter]
he's like an elon musk type like yeah
he's the creator of jolly beans jolly
bee joe's like
versus the capitalists yeah right now
you know so it's like he's like the
[ __ ] heroes he's like captain america
but captain vietnam oh right and then
his his anti-hero is the [ __ ] the
villain yeah jollibee jones jolly who's
a tycoon kind of a sick name that's got
a fire i'm gonna take my instagram name
today
you know spreading fried chicken all
over the world but in reality it's like
sprinkled meth or something right oh
[ __ ] he's trying to go to vietnam but uh
and then he's like nah we you're gonna
bring that [ __ ] yeah i'm not in our
country yeah and he's fighting back he's
fine what's the character what's your
character's name van van van friend
pandrea
fan trends
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ] what a great writer's room huh
dude this is awesome
we should create a writer's room and
[ __ ] pitch a show yeah do it let's do
it now
[Music]
[Music]